à l'âge de 12 ans si j'étais tombé sur
une vidéo comme ça un témoignage comme
ça je me serais rendu compte que ce que
je vivais n'était pas normal et donc
j'aurais parlé
c'était un soir ou ma mère n'était pas
là il s'approchait de moi et puis elle
sait sa main sous la couette et
l'adresse elle me dérange pas
découpez mon perdu en fait j'ai
l'impression que j'allais mourir chaque
jour tu vois
qu'on se brosser j'essaie de
j'ai pas eu l'enfance que n'importe quel
enfant a le droit
ça va
et je suis né à 15 ans et demi gros
bisous
j'avoue c'était un film tu vois
salut c'est Juliette aujourd'hui je
voulais vous raconter l'histoire de
Cannes pendant plusieurs années Cam a
été victime d'inceste de la part de son
père elle a vécu avec plusieurs familles
d'accueil et aujourd'hui elle a 22 ans
elle a accepté de nous raconter son
histoire
j'ai pas trop changé j'ai envie de dire
elle m'a accueilli chez elle à Nantes
pour me raconter ce qu'elle a vécu c'est
un témoignage difficile à entendre mais
il m'a beaucoup touché et j'ai
l'impression d'avoir pu comprendre un
peu plus les mécanismes qui maintiennent
certaines victimes dans le silence
absolu elles empêchent d'en parler
pendant des années et parfois même toute
une vie ça c'est du coup c'est Dominique
donc que tu verras aussi extra la procès
c'est la première famille c'est ma
première famille donc là c'est des
souvenirs plutôt positifs que tu as
c'était méga positif vraiment ça se voit
mon sourire je viens de dire c'était
l'époque où j'étais plutôt très heureuse
c'est Dominique et Pascal du coup ne
sont compagnon
j'aime trop cette photo là je me trouve
trop mignonne dessus vraiment je la
trouve trop belle
[Musique]
avec Dominique c'était
on va dire la famille que je méritais tu
vois genre c'était le bonheur que je
méritais
[Musique]
depuis qu'elle est toute petite cam vie
et une enfance difficile à l'âge de 4
ans elle est placée en foyer parce que
ses parents ne sont pas en capacité de
s'occuper d'elle et à l'âge de 6 ans
elle entre en famille d'accueil
progressivement elle commence à revoir
ses parents d'abord une fois par mois et
ensuite elle les voit tous les weekends
ça a été vraiment avec le recul c'est
pour ça que déjà j'arrive pas à
comprendre comment s'est passé du rêve
au cauchemars sincèrement mais ça a été
les week-ends les plus beaux de ma vie
genre vraiment c'était on est allé faire
du karting tous les week-ends
en gros ça me retransmettait un vraiment
un sentiment de bien-être avec eux tu
vois vraiment c'était c'était incroyable
en apparence tout se passe bien et quand
même fini par rentrer définitivement
chez elle mais ce qu'elle nous dit à
personne c'est que quelques weekends
avant de rentrer chez elle elle avait
son père frapper sa mère en tant
qu'enfant j'ai forcé aussi pour rentrer
chez mes parents parce que parce que
juste je voulais aussi rentrer tu vois
c'était mes parents donc voilà mais
ouais du coup j'en ai pas parlé mais en
fait que je savais que c'était pas
normal mais j'étais mes parents donc pas
je fais rien dire quand j'y repense
c'était vraiment assez ouf à quel point
j'étais manipulé
l'autre secret qu'elle ne se dira
personne c'est que peu de temps avant de
rentrer chez elle son père a commencé à
abuser d'elle
du premier soir qui était approché
c'était un soir où ma mère n'était pas
là et
en gros j'étais dans ma chambre et puis
il est venue il s'approchait de moi puis
il s'est sa main sous la couette et
Mademoiselle ça me dérange pas voilà
c'est le premier souvenir que j'ai
ensuite j'ai pas en fait j'ai pas
vraiment de souvenir de de vraiment
comment ça a démarré j'ai c'est
totalement flou
enfin c'est même si je suis victime
d'adnésie traumatiques tu vois quand
elle rentre définitivement chez elle sa
situation s'aggrave peu de temps après
son retour son père personne emploi et
passe toutes ces journées à la maison
seule avec cam ma mère partait au
travail vers 19h et de 19 à 8h du matin
du coup j'étais toute seule avec lui
donc ouais j'étais vraiment toute seule
toute seule tout le temps
ça a complètement dérapé quand j'étais
en quatrième donc vers je crois que
j'avais 13 ans comme ça
et là où bah ma puberté avait quand même
bien avancé et en fait ou juste il s'est
mis en tête de d'aller plus loin quoi
donc voilà
de ces 10 ans et demi jusqu'à ses 15 ans
et demi cam sera victime plusieurs fois
par semaine d'acte incestueux de la part
de son père en fait
c'est
j'en ai honte honnêtement mais en fait
le problème de tout ce que j'ai vécu
c'est que mon père était quelqu'un de
très gulard il était violent envers les
objets envers les murs vous pouvez péter
des câbles très facilement tu vois ce
qui fait que le côté
sexuel on va dire c'était le seul moyen
de le calmer et c'était mon seul moyen
de me dire ok il va pas gueuler tu vois
genre c'est le moyen où je sais qu'il
était très doux et par exemple un soir
ou enfin les soirs où j'avais un peu
peur si je peux dire qu'il pète un câble
mais du coup le seul remède le seul la
seule échappatoire c'était d'accepter
qui se passe qui se passait
parce que tous les les faits de violence
sexuelles etc ça a été toujours fait
dans la douceur et du coup j'ai pas eu
l'impression
c'est horrible à dire vraiment je sais
que c'est mal je sais que que j'ai pas
envie mais en même temps quand je disais
c'est ma seule échappatoire pour que
pour que ce soit apaisé à la maison tu
vois que j'ai pas peur de mourir en fait
tout simplement parce que la première
fois qu'il m'a frappé pour moi ça a été
le jour où genre chaque jour qui
découlait j'ai l'impression que j'allais
mourir chaque jour tu vois genre
t'es complètement perdu en fait tu es
manipulé et puis en même temps tu es en
mode j'ai pas envie mais en même temps
c'est le seul moyen que j'ai enfin
vraiment c'est c'est un combat dans ta
tête et t'imagines même pas puis en plus
tu as aucun référentiel tu connais pas
la situation des autres parce que je ne
sortais pas je vais pas avoir mes amis
enfin on était une famille très enfermée
en plus donc vraiment j'avais aucun
autre
comparaison j'avais connu que ça donc
ouais c'était c'était compliqué
[Musique]
c'était un film tu vois genre tellement
c'est
je comprends pas genre c'est trop tu
vois
ça c'était Londres du coup c'était le
voyage que j'ai fait juste avant de de
partir de chez mes parents
définitivement je pense que là on le
voit un peu plus sur cette photo j'ai
l'impression de ce qu'on voit que je
suis là mais pas à la fin moi je connais
mon regard tu vois je le sais mais je
faisais semblant enfin c'était pas moi
c'était un film c'était pas c'était pas
c'était pas vraiment moi et
c'était une Camille malheureuse c'était
une Camille
c'était compliqué quoi
c'est compliqué je pense que ouais
c'était on échappatoire tu vois j'étais
contente de partir une semaine en dehors
de la maison plus c'était très compliqué
à ce moment là avec mon père parce que
lui il s'est mis des objectifs en tête
et puis moi j'étais avec mon petit
copain de l'époque et
c'était compliqué parce que logiquement
tu vois quand j'ai l'impression de
tromper mon petit copain bref c'était
compliqué
à ce moment là elle est en couple avec
son premier copain son père n'est pas au
courant mais quand elle rentre de
Londres il le découvre et en apprenant
il la met à la rue c'est comme ça qu'à
15 ans et demi comme se retrouve de
nouveau prise en charge par les services
sociaux et placer dans une nouvelle
famille d'accueil où elle rencontre
celle qu'elle considère encore
aujourd'hui comme sa maman de coeur
du coup là c'est co c'est ma deuxième
paire d'accueil que chez qui j'étais
accueilli donc en 2016 du coup et Dan
donc son compagnon Célia et moi du coup
j'ai pas eu l'enfance que n'importe quel
enfant a le droit
et quand je suis à vainqueur et demi
j'ai redémarré 3-0 en fait je me suis
dit bah c'est ma chance donc on
redémarre tout
[Musique]
et je suis né le 15 en ligne voilà
et les vieux la technologie il va
t'envoyer une vidéo
pour moi
allez fais-moi un gros bisous
[Rires]
quand tu dis que tu as commencé à vivre
à 15 ans c'est avec quoi
c'est franchement c'est une femme
extraordinaire j'ai pas je peux pas dire
elle est incroyable c'est une femme je
souhaite à tout le monde de rencontrer
une dans sa vie il faut une cour c'est
la première personne adulte en dehors de
mon premier petit copain à qui j'en ai
parlé donc en gros j'ai j'ai les
premiers les premiers aveugles que j'ai
fait c'était à Alexandre du coup mon
premier amour et en fait il m'a poussé
en parler à Co et du coup bah j'en ai
j'en ai parlé à cause de toi au courant
et c'est elle qui m'a poussé en fait à
en parler à l'aise en 2017 soit un an et
demi après la fin des faits un
signalement à l'aide sociale à l'enfance
et ensuite à la police elle porte
plainte contre ses parents son père est
notamment jugé pour viol incestueux sur
mineur et sa mère notamment pour non
dénonciation d'un acte sexuel contre
mineur quand je rencontre cam elle est
en pleine préparation du procès pour
qu'elle puisse nous raconter les gens
qui précèdent ce moment important dans
sa vie je lui ai passé une petite caméra
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu sais que tu es fatigué
psychologiquement et que tu es très très
fatiguée parce que quand tu te couches
en après-midi tu te dis je dors 45
minutes pour une sieste et que tu dors
trois heures
je me réveiller
je suis fatiguée
[Applaudissements]
je travaille tout le temps
j'essaie de combler le moindre petit
trou que je peux faire le travail et
on va essayer je pense pas
je sais de pas penser au brosser
j'essaie de
j'y arrive pas
j'arrive mais en même temps je n'y
arrive pas tu vois
pour dire je suis exténuée je suis
stressée je suis
je suis pas bien
est-ce que tu as le droit en parlant de
notes de prendre des notes non tu ne
viens pas avec des notes je te l'avais
dit personne ne vient avec ses notes la
vérité tu la connais le dossier tu le
connais ton histoire tu la connais et
je pourrais le répéter 600 fois que de
toute façon ça ne se passera pas comme
tu l'as répété
j'ai mal au ventre tellement je me sens
je me sens pas bien je me sens
que
je me sens je me sens pas bien sûr genre
c'est compliqué
[Musique]
pour résumer la journée d'hier du coup
j'ai eu mon appel
j'ai mon appel aussi avec ma famille
d'accueil du coup je pense que tu vas
être contente parce que je vais la voir
cet après-midi je vais aller acheter
avec elle des tenues
pour l'audience donc je suis en train de
préparer pour ça normalement demain je
vais chez le coiffeur aussi
bon
c'est parti je suis vraiment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je présente la marine pierre voilà ma
petite Coco
[Musique]
vraiment c'est
l'amour de ma vie cette femme je l'aime
infiniment
enfin bref
pour se mettre en relation et faire
confiance
aux gens
tu vois là je suis avec Axel et ce qui
fait que je me sens si bien c'est le
fait que c'est quelqu'un d'hyper doux
c'est quelqu'un de très à l'écoute qui
qui est aussi plus âgé que moi mine de
rien et ce qui fait qu'il a un recul
beaucoup plus important une maturité qui
n'est pas la même que les que les hommes
de mon âge pour moi c'était une sorte
d'évidence tu vois
[Musique]
honnêtement j'ai appris à connaître cam
genre sans histoire qu'elle avait avant
et pour la personne qui allait
aujourd'hui et du coup j'ai jamais
spécialement eu de blocage ou de peur de
la heurter et tout on a tellement
toujours été sincère entre nous honnête
dans la confiance etc que j'ai jamais
forcément eu la crainte de faire le
geste de trop ou ce genre de choses et
elle me l'a toujours dit j'avoue quand
j'ai toujours été comme ça avec elle
j'aurais voulu pas qu'on la voit genre
de par son passé mais plus de comment
aller maintenant et pour le coup moi
j'en ai des blocages et genre même si
genre j'essaie de pas trop me prendre la
tête et tout c'est vrai que des fois il
va y avoir un geste une odeur un acte
etc et des fois ça va me ramener sans le
vouloir
il y a quelques années en arrière tu
vois donc
comment guérit tout ça comment est-ce
que tu essayes de te guérir comment
est-ce que tu guéris pas tu guéris pas
c'est pas quelque chose quelque chose
que
déjà tu dois accepter que ça s'est passé
il faut que tu te fasses soigner que tu
fasses accompagner tu vois moi je sais
que par exemple j'ai pas encore cette
force de me faire accompagner par un psy
j'arrive pas je pense que c'est ce que
je veux pas faire face à tout ce qui
s'est passé et je me suis mise en tête
de reprendre une thérapie quand le
process sera passé parce que je veux un
terme à cette histoire tu vois je veux
que oui c'est bon c'est fini maintenant
je peux travailler sur
ce qui va par entre guillemets tu vois
j'ai du mal et moi c'est un problème
parce que quand je vais dans la rue et
je vois une petite tenir la main de son
père dirait que j'imagine le pire c'est
une horreur c'est une horreur genre
alors que c'est Adidas tu vois genre
juste c'est une petite qui tient la main
de son père mais
mais psychologiquement genre c'est une
bataille sans cesse que j'ai dans ma
tête
ça du coup les seules photos que j'ai de
mon père
enfin
c'est un truc de malade je
pense pas
[Musique]
je peux pas m'empêcher de comparer avec
maintenant tu vois avec comment il a
évolué et c'est ça qui me fait du mal je
pense et
parce que
j'ai l'impression que
je l'ai détruit tu vois
donc c'est un peu c'est un peu dur c'est
même super dur genre j'ai l'impression
que ouais qui qu'aujourd'hui il est
malheureux que c'est de ma faute
moi c'est compliqué je stresse beaucoup
de les revoir je stresse énormément
c'est une épreuve encore une fois assez
me remettre dedans c'est
être confronté à la réalité qu'ils
existent bel et bien
parce que bah quand tu évolues sans tes
parents depuis autant d'années tu as
l'impression entre guillemets qui
s'existe plus vraiment son purement de
ce monde et du coup quand tu es
confronté à eux si ils sont bien là le
passé a bien eu lieu et tout ça quoi
donc oui j'avoue que ça me stresse
beaucoup de les revoir
[Musique]
bonjour
je viens de recevoir un courriel de la
présidence le dossier va être renvoyé
lundi matin
je t'explique l'avocat général a un
problème et indisponible et il n'en
trouver personne pour le remplacer ça
veut dire que il y a en gros les dates
de procès sont décalées
ne peut pas avoir lieu lundi mardi
mercredi elle le renvoie à une autre
session à une autre date d'audience
je sais que c'est dur
si j'avais simplement le pouvoir de
modifier le
chat je le ferai moi je sais qui est
prête pour ce procès je suis prête on
est prêts
voilà je le sais bon tu m'envoies
un petit message quoi qu'il arrive pour
me donner de tes nouvelles
merci beaucoup
[Musique]
oui Camille
je compatisé l'étoile je comprends mais
allez mets du soleil dans la tête c'est
reporté c'est pas annuler
[Musique]
du coup il y aura juste un début
d'audience lundi matin pour dire il y a
pas d'avocat général et du coup renvoyé
il faut qu'on se présente quand même
plein faut qu'on se présente tous
et ça y est
va te prendre un petit goûter avec lui
je pense que je vais les emmener à la
crêperie j'ai envie de Nutella être
gentille
on arrive toujours à rire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
samedi jour 953
on marche ça va ça va
c'est pas non plus le top du top mais
fallait que je m'attendais à autre chose
de ce week-end
[Musique]
et aujourd'hui il y a
danse avec
le procès
pour faire rire les situations les plus
cocasses et moins drôle du monde
d'affaires c'est faux
ouais c'est pas
en fait me dire que j'y vais pour déjà
10 minutes ça me saoule j'ai pas envie
je trouve super quelque chose qui est
pas forcément nécessaire mais
c'est pas grave
merci d'être venu le chercher
mon beau costume bleu j'ai mis une
chemise blanche
et puis je sais pas comment j'ai fait
c'est la première fois je me tâche avec
du fond de teint comme par hasard ce
jour-là du coup j'ai mis
je me suis endormie était 5h du matin
nous étions connectés par la pensée à
droite si tu veux
ouais à gauche
je n'aime pas la prochaine si je peux
l'éviter c'est
pas trop de souvenir
c'est assez dur quand même le devoir de
les voir c'était pas simple ça fait
depuis 2015 que je les ai quittés en
2017 j'ai porté plainte et quand j'ai
porté plainte ma mère à soutenu mon père
de A à Z en fait perdre sa maman c'est
super dur et
j'espère au fond que oui sachant quelque
chose tu vois que après l'audience enfin
après le procès potentiellement je
pourrais au moins reprendre contact avec
elle que je pourrais pouvoir discuter un
petit peu et savoir un petit peu ce
qu'elle a vécu la comprendre parce que
c'est vrai que maintenant je suis adulte
donc je suis plus capable de la
comprendre tu vois je suis positive
j'essaie toujours d'être positive de
toute façon
les parents de Cam n'ont donc toujours
pas été jugés le procès aura lieu un peu
plus tard cette année en France une
personne sur dix affirme avoir été
victime d'inceste des garçons et surtout
des filles de tous les milieux sociaux
sont concernés la première agression
survient en moyenne à l'âge de 9 ans si
vous ou un de vos proches et de victimes
vous devez en parler vous pouvez appeler
le 119 c'est le numéro d'appel national
de l'enfance en danger et il est gratuit
et ouvert 24 heures sur 4 à l'âge de 12
ans si j'étais tombée sur une vidéo
comme ça un témoignage comme ça je me
serais rendu compte que ce que j'y vais
n'était pas normal et donc j'aurais
parlé mais beaucoup plus tôt tu vois et
j'aurais pas attendu des années je veux
que des enfants des jeunes tombent
là-dessus que des parents tombent
là-dessus pour sensibiliser leurs
enfants tu vois c'est tout con mais les
parents ne parlent pas assez à leurs
enfants en mode si nanana te touche il
n'a pas le droit non on parle pas de ça
c'est trop tabou tu vois et du coup
forcément aider aussi ceux qui ont vécu
ça et qui aujourd'hui sont en mode j'ose
pas en parler et je veux dire que si il
faut en parler ce que tu ne peux pas
garder ça à l'intérieur c'est pas
possible si tu gardes à l'intérieur tu
vas pas pouvoir vivre en fait et je veux
juste en fait ouais balancer ce message
d'espoir à toutes les personnes qui qui
voient le témoignage tout simplement
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
j'espère qu'elle vous a intéressé si
vous avez d'autres idées de sujets
n'hésitez pas à m'envoyer un message sur
Instagram et on se voit bientôt à la
prochaine